with grocery prices so high your garden
can come to your rescue as growing your
food has never been more important as a
single parent and solo Gardener I found
the top 10 essential crops that offer
the most value to feed your family join
me as I share my personal tips and
tricks to help you maximize your garden
potential and stretch your budget
further
[Music]
over the years I've discovered which
crops are the best for maximizing yield
and nutrition helping me stretch my
budget further from staple vegetables to
versatile herbs these crops are easy to
grow they're easy to bring to the table
and of course incredibly rewarding too
for the past 11 years I've been growing
in two different large Gardens my most
recent one being 28 raised beds I've
experimented with several different
varieties of peppers and tomatoes summer
and winter squashes pumpkins several
varieties of herbs potatoes sweet
potatoes onions garlic carrots parsnips
beets radishes cantaloupe and
watermelons um salad greens beans peas
corn tomatillos ground cherries
cucumbers and last to name a few these
past 11 years have been here in South
Carolina and before that I grew some of
these things in a much shorter growing
season up in Michigan now that I'm
moving it's going to be in the same area
I'm just downsizing I'm really trying to
analyze the things I've grown throughout
the years so that I can choose the
highest value crops for my smaller space
that are really going to help me cut my
grocery bill and feed my kids and I July
is the peak of the summer growing season
for most of us but it's also time to
think about summer planted crops that
will be harvested and fall and also
crops like garlic that are planted in
the fall here where I am in upstate
South Carolina that's mid October
there's also never a wrong time to think
about next year's Garden let's get down
to these top 10 valuable crops in no
particular order I grow hundreds of
dollars worth of herbs every single year
there are so many varieties of herbs and
most are really extremely easy to grow
in most climates there are varieties you
can grow that are perennials and that
means they're going to come back in the
spring year after year some of these
include chives mint Sage Thyme and also
Rosemary I know you've seen herbs in the
store but they are so expensive whether
fresh or dry and you can only imagine
the amount of them you could grow in
containers I've had chives growing from
the same initial plants that I started
from seed years ago and then every year
I divide them and rejuvenate them and
plant them in different places I do like
to grow almost all of my herbs and grow
bags because that keeps the ones that
spread separate from my actual raised
garden beds and they're also portable I
love that part based on the things that
I consistently cook for my family I
always grow my staple herbs which are
parsley basil chives and cilantro I've
also grown certain herbs for tea like
mint and lavender I use all of my herbs
both fresh and I also dehydrate them
they're also so very easy to preserve
you cannot go wrong with them you can
even freeze them in little cubes with
olive oil that you can conveniently
access while you're cooking you can also
grow hundreds of dollars worth of salad
greens even in very small spaces there
are lettuce varieties made for your
specific microclimate guaranteed lettuce
varieties I think are so much fun to
shop for and experiment with and one
seed packet will grow you at least a
couple dozen of those plastic pre-washed
containers of lettuce that you can find
at the store even if you live in a
Northern climate with a shorter growing
season you can extend your season by
covering your plants or using an easy
DIY hoop house if you live in a hotter
climate like this you can extend your
growing season since lettuce is normally
a cool season Croc by buying heat
resistant varieties and using shade
cloth lettuce is absolutely another
versatile crop that you can grow in
containers I used to grow it in
containers on my deck in Michigan I
don't know if you like kale or chard but
I'm trying to like those better because
they're so easy to grow and they really
do provide a bulky amount of greens they
just have haven't really been my
favorite but I'd like to keep trying and
making things like soups kale chips and
using them in my daily smoothies really
no matter how you eat your greens
growing your own will provide more
nutrition while reducing your grocery
bill really now we need to talk about
sweet corn because it's a staple crop
that you can grow a lot of in raised
beds I've even seen gardening friends
growing it successfully in grow bags I
made a really detailed video about how
to grow sweet corn successfully in your
backyard garden so I'm just going to
touch on a couple of the main points
here you can grow a lot of it at home
it's easy to grow and it's also
versatile in the ways that you can
preserve it which is huge when you're
trying to save money on groceries my
favorite way is to pressure can it but
lots of people prefer to freeze it to
use in recipes and eat as a nutritious
side dish throughout the year until
there's more fresh corn available from
the garden it can even be dehydrated for
long-term storage and if you grow an
open pollinated variety you can save
your seeds every single year it's really
easy to dry ears of corn as long as
they're kept away from birds and
squirrels because they will go out after
them in a split second two fruits I've
been consistently growing for the past
11 years are blueberries and
strawberries also if you have the space
raspberries and blackberries are totally
worth it because they're really low
maintenance and as you know they're
really expensive at the store I started
out with be root strawberry and
blueberry plants that I ordered online
from Organic Farms blueberry bushes are
going to produce for years but it does
take a few years to get them producing
heavily depending on the age of the
bushes that you're starting with you do
have to keep an eye on your soil because
they Thrive and more acidic conditions
blueberry bushes can self-pollinate but
for best results plant at least two
different varieties because you're going
to get a bigger crop of fatter sweeter
blueberries if they bloom at the same
time and then cross-pollinate you can
buy bar root strawberry plants once and
get free Plants every year by
propagating the runners I've made
detailed videos about this if you'd like
to see how to have fresh strawberry
Harvest every year both blueberries and
strawberries are versatile and can be
grown in containers squash is another
high value crop that can provide a lot
of versatile and nutritious food for
your family I've grown a lot of
different varieties of squash but I've
really honed in on zucchini butternut
and spaghetti over the past few years in
my raised beds I would actually really
like to look for varieties that the
squash Vine borers don't like because
they're so bad in my area and growing
varieties that they don't like is
probably the least maintenance and best
way to prevent their damage winter
squash stores for longer than zucchini
but I really like to make freezer meals
like zucchini enchiladas that my kids
really love and also zucchini bread and
I just freeze the loes I'm just going to
go ahead and group cucumbers with the
squash because they're also cucurbits I
grow cucumbers every single summer
because my kids and I love them but the
plants are also really prolific and the
cucumbers are so hydrating and delicious
to eat in the summertime broccoli
versatility makes it a valuable crop to
have on hand for meal planning and by
the way this is my bolted beta broccoli
that I just left alone after it started
to bolt earlier this summer because
we're moving broccoli is a cool season
crop so depending on your location it
can be grown both in the spring and the
fall which of course extends your
gardening season allowing you to have
fresh produce for a longer period
throughout the year here where I live I
have the best Harvest when I plant in
the late summer and then I harvest
around December but you can also plant
an early spring for a summer Harvest I
like to harvest my broccoli all at once
and then steam it and freeze it to pull
out as side dishes for the upcoming
months my kids will actually only eat
garden broccoli and I can't blame them
because the flavor is absolutely amazing
compared to store-bought broccoli I've
also figured out that bellstar broccoli
does the best in my garden so my
experience is to experiment with
varieties and until you find one that
loves your garden it's a lot easier to
grow than you think it is and if you're
growing it in the fall you're going to
most likely notice that there is way
less pest pressures tomatoes and peppers
peppers and tomatoes the quintessential
summertime heat loving crops and I kind
of group those together as one crop we
love tomatoes and peppers fresh in
salads sandwiches salsa and in sauces
I've also done my share of canning them
for salsa and sauce I've also Frozen
Roma tomatoes which I chop and use and
things like omelets and frittatas I've
chopped and Frozen and also dehydrated
Peppers to use in dishes like chili I
love pimento peppers and I love pimento
cheese and I love all different
varieties of hot peppers and I've canned
them but they're kind of a treat for us
and they're not really a household
staple so those varieties with the
exception of my favorite purple
jalapenos that I can't go without I'll
squeeze those plants in if I have the
space in my garden it really depends on
how you like to eat your tomatoes and
peppers but you can see that they're a
very versatile crop there are tons of
different varieties they are really easy
to preserve and they provide a lot of
food growing potatoes at home can
significantly reduce grocery costs
especially considering their high yield
and storage capabilities they can
produce a large yield from a relatively
small planting area in each little sea
potato piece planted yields multiple
potatoes providing an abundant Harvest
for you you know how versatile they are
in the kitchen and growing them at home
allows you to choose varieties you can't
even find at the store if your climate
allows and one stored properly in a cool
dark place potatoes can last for several
months if you're able to store them
longterm you can save them to plant The
Following season I've grown potatoes in
raised beds and lots of gardeners have
success growing them in large grow bags
I found sweet potatoes to be even easier
to grow and they store for a bit longer
for me in the pantry since I lack a cool
dry location in our climate you can buy
slips online or they're really easy to
start Yourself by just setting a few
sweet potatoes aside one raised bed can
yield hundreds of dollars worth of
nutrient packed sweet potatoes whole
beans and Bush Beans I think are the
easiest Garden crop to grow and the
seeds are so easy to save year after
year and have high germination rates
making them even more valuable in the
garden they're also legume so they
provide nitrogen fixation in the soil
after the plants die enriching the soil
and improving fertility for future crops
depending on when you harvest they can
be eaten as green beans shelling beans
or saved as dry beans to use in things
like chili and reff fried beans the
plants behind me are pretty much on
their last leg because I've let them go
so that I can dry these out and take the
seeds with me when we move beans can be
grown in a wide range of climates and
soil types making them adaptable to lots
of different gardening environments and
pole beans can be grown vertically to
maximize limited gardening space they
continue producing over an extended
period allowing for multiple Harvest
from the same plants I usually grow
rattlesnake beans because I like the
Savory and nutty flavor when they're
dried similar to pinto beans and they
make the best refried beans in the whole
entire world in terms of preserving I've
pressure canned green beans but my
favorite way to preserve them is to let
them dry out right on the plants and use
the dried beans in lots of different
meals throughout the year and finally
garlic is another really easy to grow
and low-maintenance crop that I keep
growing every year because you get a lot
of bang for your buck you get one whole
garlic bulb from each little clove you
plant and like the previous nine crops
we've talked about fresh garlic is
expensive to buy at the store especially
organic varieties most varieties you
can't even find in the store you can use
it fresh you can use it roasted dried
powdered and pickled making it a really
versatile Staple in the kitchen it's
easy to store long term so you can keep
your best bulbs for replanting every
single year I always grow garlic and
rais beds but it can can also be grown
in containers another benefit of garlic
is that it's in the ground for months
while being a natural pest deterrent for
most vulnerable plants making it a great
companion plant protecting from pests
like aphids and spidermites man that
breeze feels
good thank you for joining me today and
exploring the top 10 essential Garden
crops that I think can help feed your
family and stretch your budget further
remember though that growing your own
food not only provides fresh nutritious
produce but it also brings a huge sense
of accomplishment and sustainability
whether you're a seasoned Gardener or
just starting out these 10 crops are
sure to make a big impact on your garden
and your table if you'd like I'd love it
if you'd share your own favorite staple
Garden crops in the comments below and I
hope you'll join me again in the garden